ROBOT:
This is a story of automation
and of the people
lost in the process.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
MAN 1:
There was this accident.
A robot killed a man.
MAN 2: It just didn't stop.
It was the very first death
in a driverless car.
MAN 3: Any kind of work that
is fundamentally routine
and repetitive is going
to disappear
because AI is going to be
everywhere.
We don't want
to replace the worker,
we want to support workers.
MAN 4: We're talking about
machines now that are so cheap,
they do exactly what
a human does with less money.
MAN 3: Huge numbers of people
feel they are being left behind.
They're right, they are.
MAN 1: The biggest danger
of that is the discrediting
of our empathetic responses.
ROBOT: The dynamic between
robots and humans changed.
You could no longer tell
where you ended...
and we began.